Of all the deadliest, nastiest, most monstrous
creatures contained by the SCP Foundation,
there is none quite like SCP-682.
A mean, green, perpetual motion killing machine,
this beast runs on spite and unnatural strength,
fueled by hatred and an unslakable thirst
for violence.
With no known way of permanently destroying
the thing, SCP-682 is likely to remain in
Foundation custody until the sun burns out.
Unless, of course, the research staff can
finally crack the code on killing the thing
once and for all.
But one scientist at the SCP Foundation couldn't
help but wonder: did violence really have
to be the answer?
Was the only way to manage SCP-682's hateful
heart to stop it from beating?
Dr. Bright was having his weekly movie night,
joined this time by SCP-507, who loved a good
film whenever he was in a dimension that happened
to have them.
He had campaigned for a viewing of "The Avengers,"
but Dr. Bright insisted on something a little
more heartfelt.
He remembered a book that his mother used
to read to him, and recalled that it had been
adapted into a movie.
So, in spite of SCP-507's sulking, he pressed
play on "Black Beauty."
The story of a wild creature forming a bond
with a determined young girl, the two learning
and growing with each other and embarking
on an unlikely friendship, brought tears to
his eyes.
If she could tame that wild stallion, then
why couldn't he, a man of infinite patience
and even more infinite time, try and tame
a wild beast of his own?
That settled it.
He was going to take a stand, to try something
the Foundation had never dared attempt with
SCP-682.
He was going to become its friend.
"Are you out of your mind?!"
Dr. Gears nearly dropped his mug of plain
black coffee when Dr. Bright told him the
plan.
"That thing will tear you limb from limb before
you can so much as say a word."
"Then I'll get another body.
I'm willing to put in the work."
Dr. Bright shrugged, but as he looked at Dr.
Gears' look of deep concern, he decided that
it would be better to ask for forgiveness
than permission at this point.
He had to misdirect, and fast.
"Ha!
I got you, look at your face!
That was a prank, I'm kidding, I would never
try that.
Anyway, lots to do, bye!"
And he rushed off to undertake his grand vision
by himself.
When it worked, then he could make the rounds
around the Foundation Site with his "I told
you so"s.
Dr. Bright hadn't grown up on a horse ranch,
he hadn't even grown up with many pets.
He had no idea where to begin when it came
to animal training, let alone the domestication
of highly intelligent, misanthropic, anomalous
animals.
For an anomalous being, perhaps he needed
to try an anomalous method of taming it.
Suddenly, it occurred to him: SCP-010!
That could work!
The iron collars were stored at Site-19, in
locked boxes.
When worn, they would allow the wearer's every
movement to be controlled via a hand-held
remote.
It was perfect.
He could get SCP-682 to give him a hug, a
high-five, to learn choreographed dance routines
they could perform together, the possibilities
were endless!
But when he went to access the locked storage
boxes, the guards posted outside the room
asked him what he was doing there.
"Testing, it's all official," he said.
But the guards insisted that they would have
been notified if any testing had been approved.
He tried to argue with them, but as soon as
he saw their expressions turn suspicious,
he pivoted hard in a safer direction.
"Just kidding!
Pranked.
Got you good."
"Hah, yeah, you got us, Doc."
One of the guards forced a chuckle.
"Stay safe out there!"
"Not if I see you first!"
Doctor Bright responded, realizing only later
that his response made no sense.
Damn adrenaline, the thrill of the scheme
was making him loopy.
He needed to center himself, to refocus and
figure out what his next step would be.
If the collar had any chance of working on
the massive reptile, the Foundation probably
would have tried it before...and if he tried
to sneak in and just steal one of the damn
things, someone might see him, then his plan
would be over before it even began.
Besides, he reminded himself, he was trying
to befriend SCP-682, not just pilot its movements
like some kind of giant remote-control toy.
If it listened to him, it needed to be because
it wanted to.
Because they had formed a sacred bond between
man and beast.
No, SCP-010 wasn't the answer.
He needed to get the opinion of an expert,
hear advice from someone who really knew what
they were doing.
He hopped online, and found exactly what he
was looking for: an online seminar on training
difficult animals.
Okay, it was specifically a webinar about
obedience training for dogs with behavioral
problems, but what was SCP-682 if not a massive,
reptilian dog with a whole lot of behavioral
problems?
Besides, the webinar was only 50 dollars,
so really what could it hurt?
Dr. Bright kicked up his feet, poured himself
a drink, and tuned into the video seminar.
Once the credit card payment went through,
and the five-hour session was through, he
would know exactly what to do to take SCP-682
from Keter to Cutie.
Well, maybe that was a bit much.
But stranger things happened every day.
After all, he was a guy whose soul was trapped
in a necklace for all eternity.
With a beeping sound, the live video began,
and Dr. Bright prepared to absorb all of the
wisdom Dr. Monique, PhD in Animal Psychology,
had to offer.
He nodded off a few times, but for the most
part, he was able to retain some very valuable
tips.
First, go slowly.
Start working with your dog (or giant anomalous
reptile) on familiar behaviors, or their favorite
things to do.
Use positive reinforcement to encourage even
the smallest of successes.
This will teach the pet that training is a
good thing.
To ease the transition, only make one change
at a time.
Next, control the environment.
During training sessions, take away potential
distractions to help your pet stay focused.
Put away toys they might be tempted to play
with (or things they might try to eat).
Minimize loud noises and other intrusions,
such as passing squirrels.
Avoid punishment, as it can increase anxiety
and damage the relationship built on trust
between pet and owner.
In the long term, punishment can serve to
increase aggression and other negative behaviors.
Instead, use reward-based training tactics
based around things the pet wants and likes,
such as treats, petting, and playtime.
When the pet does act out, redirect them to
a different behavior, then reward that.
When doing reward-based training, however,
it's important to choose the right rewards.
If the rewards aren't appealing, or given
frequently enough, they will stop evoking
the desired response in the animal.
Every animal is different, so figure out what
yours loves and give them more of that.
This particular tip might be hard to implement
for SCP-682, Dr. Bright thought as he wrote
it down.
What do you give the anomaly that hates everything?
Still, he would figure it out.
The final tips of note were to make training
a habit, part of the daily routine, made up
of short training sessions throughout the
day.
If the training failed to produce desired
results, a reasonable pet owner should be
willing to bring in help from a trained expert.
This is especially true if the animal is displaying
excessive aggression.
That one definitely applied to SCP-682, but
there was no one more qualified to handle
it than Dr. Bright was, in his own opinion
at least.
So, with no one else to call, he would have
to tackle the monumental undertaking himself.
Dr. Monique concluded her seminar by asking
each attendee about their respective pets.
Dr. Bright had to stretch the truth just a
little bit, responding only "a big one" when
asked about his dog's breed, and describing
its behavior problems as "aggression and biting."
"Well, troubled animals often just need a
little extra love and patience.
And like I said, ask for help if you need
it!
Good luck, Doctor," she said, giving him a
wave before he signed out of the meeting.
So, armed with a can-do attitude, an open
heart, a spray bottle filled with hydrochloric
acid (just in case), some toys, and as much
sliced deli turkey as the local grocery store
would sell him, Dr. Bright prepared to sneak
into SCP-682's containment cell.
He timed it perfectly, waiting for the shift
change so he could slip in unnoticed while
the guards were swapping out.
Using moves he learned from watching dozens
of heist movies, he maneuvered around the
security cameras, staying out of sight, and
let himself into the high-security containment
chamber.
Dr. Monique said to remove all distractions
while training a pet, and the acid bath that
SCP-682 was submerged in was a pretty massive
distraction.
How was Dr. Bright supposed to teach it anything
if the creature's attention was on the constant
corrosion of its flesh, muscle, and bone?
Good thing he paid attention during SCP-682's
official testing, and knew how to drain the
acid out of the room.
As SCP-682's body began to rebuild itself,
it turned to look at Dr. Bright, eyes fixed
on him.
It spoke, in a voice dripping with pure disdain:
"Why...did...you...do...that..."
"Hey buddy!"
Dr. Bright ignored the question, speaking
in a soft, higher-pitched voice that Dr. Monique
recommended for soothing troubled dogs.
"Want a treat?"
He held out a pack of sliced turkey.
Not waiting for an answer, he tossed the food
toward the reptile, and it landed just in
front of the creature's mouth with a soft
thud.
After a moment of careful study, of making
sure this was not some sort of trick, SCP-682
opened its mouth and swallowed the turkey
in one gulp.
"More..."
It said, opening its mouth wide, exposing
its rows and rows of sharp teeth.
"Wait a second.
You can have more, but first...Sit!"
Dr. Bright held up his hand to teach the command.
"Sssssit?"
The creature repeated, incredulous.
"Sit!"
Dr. Bright repeated patiently.
SCP-682 responded with a swipe of its tail
that knocked Dr. Bright into the wall, breaking
several of his ribs.
"Bad 682!
Bad!"
Dr. Bright reflexively reached for the spray
bottle, squirting some acid onto the creature's
scales.
It recoiled, and Dr. Bright became aware of
what he was doing.
He was using punishment when he should have
been using positive reinforcement.
He dropped the spray bottle, kicking it off
to the side.
"I'm so sorry buddy, that wasn't nice.
I shouldn't have..."
SCP-682 wouldn't even look at him.
"Here, you want this?
Catch?"
He held up a large ball, tossing it toward
the creature.
It bounced off the beast's nose uselessly.
"Dissssgusssting." 682 growled.
"You're right.
That was disgusting.
I forgot everything I learned, I let my ego
get in the way.
Listen, I promise I'll never do it again."
He tossed more turkey toward the creature,
and, as it ate, he gently patted its broad,
scaly side.
"I know you don't like my colleagues here.
I get it, why would you?
They're always hurting you, trying to control
you...I know what that's like.
We've got a lot in common, you know.
We've both been through so much pain.
We both can't die, even if we wanted to.
If you let me, I could be a friend to you."
SCP-682 was silent for a moment as it stared
into Dr. Bright's eyes, considering his words.
Then…
It spoke.
"You...are..."
Dr. Bright held his breath, waiting to hear
what came next.
"Disssgusssting."
SCP-682 roared.
The last thing Dr. Bright saw was the monster's
jaws clamping down around his head, and then
everything went black.
Dr. Bright woke up in his office with that
stiff "new body" feeling he had become accustomed
to.
There was a note waiting for him on his desk,
on the O5 Council's letterhead.
It read:
"Dr. Bright.
I hope you understand the gravity of what
you did today.
Your careless actions caused a containment
breach of SCP-682 that resulted in over a
dozen casualties.
Be thankful you were given a new body at all,
as it was briefly debated whether or not you
deserved one.
But you are too valuable to the Foundation
to keep locked in a box.
Remember that.
Do not interfere with SCP-682 again, or there
will be dire consequences.
Additionally, as your viewing of Black Beauty
has been attributed to this incident, all
future film viewings must be subject to formal
approval, until you can prove that this is
no longer necessary.
Now sit in your office and think about what
you've done.
- O5-1"
Dr. Bright slumped over his desk, feeling
sorry for himself.
Suddenly, he heard a familiar cooing sound
coming from the doorway.
He turned, and saw The Tickle Monster, here
to visit him and cheer him up.
It oozed over to his desk, waiting for him
to pet it.
As he patted its slimy surface, he smiled
to himself.
No matter how many mistakes he made, how much
of a screwup he might feel like sometimes,
at least he knew SCP-999 would always be happy
to see him.
Forget horses, dogs, and especially SCP-682.
Man's Best Friend was right here.
Now go check out “SCP-963 What Would You
Do If You Were Immortal Like Dr. Jack Bright?”
and “Could Dr Jack Bright Escape Silent
Hill?”